as I said it earlier anytime so that we
can during our break have a bit more
time to spare so the first talk is a la
vie Cohen from Massachusetts Institute
of Technology towards formalizing the
GDP our nose was singling out hi welcome
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
so I'm gonna tell you about this work
joint work with Kobe towards formalizing
GDP our notion of singling out paper is
not online but if you want to see see it
you can send us an email we'll send you
a draft and the first thing to say is
that this is not a talk about
differential privacy it will involve
differential privacy but this is not a
DP talk so we heard more on the on the
first day about data privacy laws and
the law is you know if we listen to Alex
or Felix tells us that they you must do
some things ABC like title 13 which
covers the census GDP are in Europe and
then there's techniques from either from
statistical disclosure limitation or
cryptography or whatever and this basic
question of does to the technique
satisfy the lost how do they help you
achieve them so this is a question that
is important and people is this thing
does this thing need to be on or is it
just for the live stream okay we're good
ok I can't hear anything so this is a
table from from document which we'll
return to at the end but I just want the
flash of this this article 21 working
party opinion it's about GDP are in
certain types of privacy attacks and
they they ask this type of question here
are some techniques here are certain
types of attacks and they say things
like hey anonymity prevents singling out
attacks and differential privacy might
not prevent singling out attacks this is
the type of question that we want to ask
but underlying these claims these are a
bunch of
we think are technical like there are
mathematical ideas those are not just
legal claims this is extremely loud I
think no not just mathematically not
just legal ideas but they're
mathematical ideas in those claims and
so what we want to do is we want to do
sort of a legal and mathematical
analysis and so start with so this is
sort of the outline of the process start
with the text of the law or some guiding
documents opinions about what the law
means and try to extract from it
something useful
that's formal and mathematical analyze
the formal mathematical thing and what
properties does that concept have how
does it relate to other concepts
mathematical concepts and then we want
to take it back to the legal regime so
we want to be able to draw legal
conclusions and so no one of these steps
is the important part it's the fact that
we're trying to do the whole circle
which is we think is the important part
and so there is some some earlier work
with a lot of authors probably half of
them or at the workshop doing something
similar for FERPA and I'm not gonna talk
about it more so in this work we're
looking at a concept called singling out
which comes from the GD P R and related
Alex sort of alluded to it on Monday we
think it's related to some concepts of
like distinguishability that is found in
other privacy laws but for the sake of
this I'm just going to talk about its
relationship to GD P R and so the the
legal concept of singling out and we
extract from it something that we call
predicate singling out it's a type of
attack and and the security notion or
privacy notion which is security against
predicate singling out like I said
analyzed its properties
and its relationship to other notions
and then try to draw a conclusion so
this is conveniently also the talk the
outline of the talk so let's start with
the first step and you ask interrupt and
ask any questions you want at any time
so the GDP our article 1 of the GDP are
it's the first part says that this the
regulation lays down rules with regards
to the processing of personal data and
recital 26 a recital is like preamble
sort of I think about it as like the
preamble to the Constitution or
something it's part of the document but
it's not an article so recital 26 says
that the regulation should not apply the
restrictions should not apply to
personal data that's been rendered
anonymous so what does this tell us it
tells us first that if it's not personal
data whatever data you're using if it's
not personal data it's not under the
purview of the GD P R and this seems to
be something that is pretty well
accepted at least that seems pretty well
accepted the recital of 26 tells us
something like it suggests that there's
something called rendering anonymous
that one might do to personal data so
maybe you can take personal data and
feed it through some magic box and out
comes something that's rendered
anonymous and the question that the
setting of this of this work is what
properties do we need from this magic
box so that its output can be considered
anonymous and not be personal data and
therefore not be under GPR restrictions
yeah yeah we're just gonna focus on it
yeah when did we start just so I know
what the time is so we have to
understand what this personal data means
in order to understand to answer this
question so article 4 of the gdpr says
the personal data is any information
relating to an ad ad identified or
identifiable natural person like we saw
in Monday
sort of a circular unclear definition
and the recital gives us a little more
it says that when thinking about what's
identify of what identifiable means
account should be taken of all the means
reasonably likely to be used such as
singling out to identify the person so
this such as singling out is sort of the
only clarification only concrete hint in
the text of the GPR as to what
identifiable so singling out is one way
to identify if identify if
identification is the big thing singling
out is one part of it there are other
things you can do to single out given a
which you see in other places not in the
text of the GTR but at least
anonymization must prevent singling out
whatever an itemization is and whatever
singling out is an organization must
prevent it so the article 20 now we have
to understand what's singling out it so
you're gonna turn to article 29 working
party opinion on the concept of personal
data these working party opinions are
some sort of official guiding document
about the law it turns out this working
party opinion was written with regards
to a predecessor of the GD P R but the
relevant parts are thought we think and
as far as we can tell if other people
think
holdover to the understanding of the GTR
so it says that a person is identified
within a group of person a group of
persons when he or she is distinguished
from all of the members from a group for
example by specifying some criteria
which allows you to narrow down the
possible individuals to a single person
okay does that make sense so you have
the personal data here some collection
of criteria is wearing a long-sleeve
white shirt and jeans and is presenting
at Simon's workshop and there's only one
person in this room at this moment that
satisfies that right we're gonna call
this this thing isolation so some
previous work this is a paper by Francis
a tall and another article were 21
Working Party opinion they understand
singling out to be the same as isolation
and we're gonna we're gonna diverge from
this and other other things we get I'm
not gonna put quotes but other things we
get from this document is that this this
P this sort of criteria doesn't have to
contain PII it doesn't have to have your
name or your email it can be things that
are just features about you it could be
some large set of properties that only
one person satisfies they're worried
about or they're they're considering it
data they is anonymous can take any form
it doesn't just have to be microdata it
can be statistics okay we are like
tabular data and and success is relative
to a particular like group of people
particularly example they give is that a
name might single out somebody in a room
but not in a country so that the room is
is X and that's the the set of people
that were go ahead maybe at this but I
thought that here does not apply to
statistical uses of
yeah so so just to the first thing I
should say is neither am i a lawyer nor
do I know almost anything about the GPR
that I'm not gonna tell you in this talk
the the second thing is that if I if I
am a company and I have data from my if
I take data from my users is it past the
like can i compute things on that data
and post it online that's that's the
question so the answer to that is yes if
that if the thing that you computed is
anonymous the thing that I computed
doesn't necessarily have to be Micro
data I could also compute tables of you
know when my users are more like likely
to use my website so I think that what
you're talking about is statistical uses
in the Census Statistical agencies sense
but I don't know the answer to this
short answer your question is I don't
know that didn't answer it go ahead the
clauses you're referring to when
statistical agencies if Gilliam's doing
it it's statistical use if you do it
it's not better answer Thanks good so
now I'm actually not gonna show you this
slide so the question is you know so
what what is this weird singling out
thing and why should we care especially
because you don't need to know the name
of the you don't need to find the name
of the person this is a clip from a
movie called democracy which is the
documentary which I think was screened
here a month or so ago about the
creation of the GPR and here is this oh
you can't see anything can you put it
over here
so hopefully sound everything works did
you bid so she's asking what's the
difference between singling out an
identification why do we care about
singling out if you don't know the names
she's finishing her questions so I can
single out that there are lots of
different people but I can't identify
any of now in real life in a classroom
the boy with the dark hair curls and and
the blue trouser completely do then
every no three days this singling out
refers to the capacity of providers on
the Internet they're able to use the
well-known attribute of this single user
by nudging someone into they that's
affected at photos they said no no this
is this is no no no point is it is
personal data without any doubt this guy
is the former something data protection
sbrick EU data protection supervisor I
think is the title head of the Dutch DPA
a head of a former head of the article
29 working party opinion group so anyway
singling out I won't belabor it but
singling out we think is a can be a
stepping stone to sort of Greater harms
and ratification also allows you to
treat somebody differently and say this
the person with the blue trousers or
whatever you leave the room even if you
don't know that person
good so now we want to take the second
step which is to try to formalize some
useful some useful motion out of this so
let's start with isolation which is
where we were before so isolation is is
when you say there's exactly one person
the data said that satisfies these
attributes and this is this is from that
paper I mentioned earlier so for example
here's some data set of pretend sort of
Netflix data set so you can see there's
exactly one person who rated the movie
crash of four there's exactly one person
who watched Moulin between a certain set
of dates and there's only one person
that doesn't satisfy the first two
predicates so each of the three rows in
this table can be singled out but can be
sorry isolated by a predicate okay so
let's try to let's set the sort of
syntactically what we're talking about
so X is going to be a data set drawn ID
from some distribution and the data set
is of size n so yes iid data sets are
not all the data sets in the world but
we're gonna restrict our attention to
this I'll come back to that restriction
later so some distribution D you pass it
through this M this is the anonymization
mechanism and you publish this output we
can think about also interactive
mechanisms then there's this adversary
who's the singling out adversary wants
to single out what do they do they
output a predicate and this predicate is
tested against X right so the
adversaries goal if we want to formalize
security against isolation as our notion
ever series goal is to output a
predicate P that matches exactly one row
in the data set there so here's a
definition we could come up with so I'm
in the mechanism is secure against
isolation if no adversary can do this
can isolate except with negligible
probability probability over X over m
over ay and if you don't know what
negligible means it just means it's some
formalization of extremely small so this
is a definition so this sort of sounds
good except there's a problem with it
it's
possible so it's impossible because I
can I can violate the definition no
matter what M is in particular I can do
it without even looking at the output of
the mechanism so here's here's an
example what I what I'm gonna do this is
my attack I'm gonna output a predicate P
star this predicate P star matches one
in n people in the distribution right so
if there's 365 people in the in the data
set then my predicate might be is born
on February 2nd that matches about one
at 365 people and the probability that
predicate isolates in the distribution
is about 37% so it's n times the
probability that that hits on any one
row is 1 in n times the probability that
the other n minus 1 rows don't don't get
it and this thing looks like 1 over e
these things cancel
it's about 37% doesn't depend on it and
and what's things didn't note are we can
do this without even knowing anything
about much about the distribution as
long as the distribution has enough
randomness and it's a point I'm going to
come back to eventually so this attacker
doesn't look at the mechanism
I'm gonna call such an attacker a
trivial attacker question saying if if
the distribution doesn't even have
support predicates that have this way
yeah great you're right there's an
asterisk here I'm gonna get to it but
yes you're right
but yeah I'll get there I'll get there
is this example clear
but somehow this somehow this was like
not that exciting if you managed to
isolate with this predicate it's it's
trivial in some sense so what makes an
attack not trivial so if that was
trivial then maybe it would not be
trivial if you use the same type of
predicate but you managed to isolate
with probability 97% instead of 37% much
better than this trivial baseline which
suggests we have to compare success with
respect to some sort of statistical
trivial baseline but 37 is not the
absolute baseline because I might be
able to learn that somebody's a vegan
Colombian Jewish pilot fluent in Dutch
which I can't say quite as well as John
can say 308 million thank you
so if you can find this predicate in the
data center like might be one person the
world that satisfies is pretty good and
you managed to do it with ten percent
probability there's something has you've
learned something from the output of the
mechanism and somehow some of this
strikes us is non-trivial so the
baseline has to depend somehow on how
rare or how specific these predicates
are
so let's make that intuition formal for
a predicate I'm gonna define its weight
as the probability that if you draw a
random person from the distribution the
person satisfies the predicate that's
what this weight of P and the baseline
is a function of N and this weight it's
the max it's the maximum probability
that a trivial adversary one that
doesn't look at the output of the
mechanism manages to isolate that's what
this notation is isolate the data set
with the predicate and also output this
predicate with this weight okay so it's
what's the probability that you the
trivial adversary can isolate with
predicate of a certain weight it's the
best probability that trivial
adversary's can do it and that's our
baseline so I'm gonna claim and this
asterisk is related to the earlier
asterisk yeah it doesn't matter it's
gonna be the same
you're because they're definitely in on
the next slide the definition is also
gonna be taken over him is conceptually
this is gonna be the same type of this
is gonna be the same probability space
as our real adversary who's not trivial
I think it's just it didn't never
thought to simplify away the M even
though I think you're right that it's
equivalent so so the claim is that the
best thing you can do is the trivial
adversary can do doesn't get to look at
the data or doesn't get to look at that
but the mechanism is just output a
predicate that has this way and just
like before it's gonna succeed with
probability n times W times 1 minus W to
the N minus 1 which looks like this
thing where n W here and W is the
expected number of hits you get on the
data set and either the - okay so what
does this thing look like it's maximized
here at 1 over n so this is graphed for
N equals 50 its maximized at 1 over N
where you reach 1 over E and it's 37%
and it's negligible when the weight gets
too high much bigger than log n over N
or when the weight itself is negligible
so like over here at this time and
that's that's the regime where we're
gonna restrict our attention to good so
now that we have some I is some notion
of this baseline we know we want to
compare against the baseline let's fix
the definition so the adversaries goal
is is to isolate with probability better
than a statistical baseline where the
baseline is a function of the predicate
sway
so this is probably the most notation
heavy slide so if you with it so here's
here's a piece of notation which is sort
of the same as we saw before the success
probability of an adversary for a given
distribution in a given mechanism and a
given weight is the probability that the
adversary isolates with the predicate
and that the weight of the predicate is
less than the weight of the predicate is
less than this way so we're gonna allow
our adversary to output predicates up to
some certain maximum weight anywhere he
wants in there in there from 0 to w is
allowed to do and the mechanism is
secure against predicate singling out
PSO secure if for all negligible weight
predicates the success probability is
negligible okay so in the negative in
the regime where W is negligible we said
that the baseline was negligible so as
long as the baseline is negligible the
adversary shouldn't do more than
negligible we also consider a more
general version of the definition where
we allow the baseline to not be
negligible in which case we compare the
adversary success probability to the
baseline we want to say that he doesn't
do much better than e to the epsilon
times the baseline plus some Delta and
in that case we'll say that it's epsilon
Delta W PSO secure where W tells us what
regime of weights it's epsilon Delta it
has this guarantee we also consider
through the the other side of the regime
of weights high weight packets but I'm
not going to talk about it for the rest
of
so any questions any questions
so we what we want to capture is
something some condition that's
necessary for GDP our anonymization so
GDP our if you were a GDP our anonymizer
you must prevent GDP are singling out
let's what we saw before and so we want
to draw this circle this yellow circle
so if we we think we have and so if if
this is the relationship if credit
security if GDP are anonymizing implies
PSO security it means that negative
results are the ones that are going to
be the easiest to draw legal conclusions
from if it doesn't satisfy PSL security
it's not going to be a GDP or anonymizer
so if this is the relationship we want
then restricting the scope of our
definition also is not it doesn't really
cause a problem so this is where this
the fact that we restrict only to iid
distributions is not so bad because if
you're going to be a GDP are anonymizer
in all the cases for all the datasets at
least you should be able to anonymize on
distributions that are datasets that
come from nice distributions also
datasets about which I have no auxilary
knowledge you should at least be able to
anonymize that in that case
and it might be that you might think
that predicate security PS social
security is very strong because the
definition we gave I sort of glossed
over it but it's it has a quantifies for
all distributions it wants security for
all distributions and all adversaries
even unbounded computation and even
non-uniform ones that know the
distribution this is an extremely strong
guarantee and maybe the GPR doesn't care
about such adversaries if the adversary
knows the distribution and has more
computing power than the NSA who cares
right
so maybe but all of our negative results
all the negative results that are the
ones that give us the strongest legal
conclusions work with a very weak
adversary who doesn't know the
distribution just knows the distribution
has some in entropy so so the negative
the the goal of getting legal
conclusions is sort of not threatened by
that quantification if you look at the
theorems themselves the proofs of the
theorems themselves
and the last question is maybe PSL
security is too weak to be meaning for
if everything's PSO secure then I'm not
gonna be able to do anything useful with
it and here the the main weakness is
this subtlety that I ignored when Ashwin
asked about it which I'm gonna talk
about now so here's the here's the
baseline that I wrote down and they
claim the adversary the trivial
adversary just outputs a predicate of
this way and so like you said maybe such
a predicate doesn't even exist there's a
more subtle problem and the more subtle
problem is that the adversary this
trivial adversary we're assuming he
knows the distribution to the X to such
an extent that he can find such a
predicate even assuming that the
predicate this way can be represented in
the distribution saying the adversary
knows the distribution so well that it
can find such a predicate and maybe such
an adversary who knows everything about
the distribution has an inflated
baseline and we're comparing against
something that's sort of artificially
high right this is and so the answer to
yeah question yeah so so right so we're
saying our secure our definition of
security says that our real adversary
can't do much better than the trivial
adversary if the trivial adversary can
do very very well this is not a very
strong notion if we defined our trivial
adversary if we if we defined a baseline
in some way that the baseline was always
a hundred percent the this whole
security notion would be vacuous right
so there's a there's a worry that if we
define the baseline in some way that
inflates it makes it higher than it
should be whatever it should be means by
giving the trivial adversary knowledge
of the distribution which may be a real
adversary doesn't have knowledge of the
do you know the distribution that the
Netflix data was drawn from no but if we
let the true if you're comparing against
the trivial adversary who knows the
distribution maybe it's an unfair
comparison you're not gonna be able to
do better but
for a stupid reason does that make sense
I don't want to dwell on it much more so
the answer to both of these issues is
that we can take nasty distributions
ones that don't as long as the
distribution has sufficient mean entropy
which is to say it's random enough how
much mean entropy a little more than log
n so if it has even a moderate amount of
randomness then we can hash it down to a
smaller space get a uniform distribution
out of it and this hashing just uses
families of hash functions you don't
have to know anything about D so you can
do this without knowing the distribution
and and without knowing how to represent
these particles you hash it and then
here you can you can represent these
these these predicates and this is also
so the trick that underlies the fact
that all our negative results have these
simple uniformed adversaries that we
don't have to know the distribution
because we can usually apply leftovers
on them okay so the end of all that got
very technical it's gonna get less
technical so if I lost everybody you
should come back there any questions
though before you continue
okay okay so now we want to ask what are
their let's understand this notion so
here's a mechanism the counting
mechanism takes a takes a predicate Q
and outputs the number of rows that
satisfy Q in the data set
exact counts is this secured against
singling out turns out it is the proof
very briefly proof idea is that this
mechanism only has a few outputs it only
can output n plus 1 numbers so your
baseline you can only do much better
than the trivial adversary by a factor
of n plus 1 and when your baseline is
negligible then end times negligible is
still not visible since I don't have
much time I'm gonna go a bit quickly so
what if a question that people often ask
is what if Q matches one row in the data
set why isn't this help you single no
does anybody can anybody see the answer
to that because I think it's important
to understand why this doesn't help
right so if I can get exact counts what
if the exact count is one can't a single
out didn't I single
so that the answer to this is that to
single out we require that the the
predicate that you output has a very
small baseline which is to say the
chance that it matches one person the
data set is extremely small and we take
randomness over the distribution so if Q
is such that if you output Q you would
have succeeded then the chance that to
match is only one person the data set is
extremely small so it's true that if you
got a count of 1 you would succeed but
the chance that you got a count of 1 is
negligible I don't know probably
so now we can ask another question now
that we know the county mechanism is
secure we can ask about whether
predicate security security against
predicate singling out is composes so if
a bunch of mechanisms are individual EPS
so secure is the collection of those
mechanisms PSO secured and the answer's
no even if you compose a little more
than log in times and we can see we can
use County mechanisms to show a counter
example so let's say this is the data
set and this is this index is called X 1
X 2 so the idea is if Q 1 if the first
predicate isolates a row then we can
learn all the bits of the row that was
isolated so how do we learn that bit so
let's say Q 1 matches one row this one
we don't know it's this one but then Q
two we can ask Q 1 and the first bit of
X is 1 right so that predict you will
either match 0 rows or 1 row depending
on whether this bit is 1 we can ask
about the second bit we can ask about
the third bit and we can go down and
after we learn enough bits then we can
specify we can just name sir naming this
row and the the weight of this predicate
that will output goes down exponentially
after you learn log in bits you're
saying and so but this is all still
conditioned on this if Q 1 isolates X
right where do we get this Q 1 but the
trivial adversary is able to isolate a
row with probability 1 over E with
probability 37% so just output it output
like a this predicate from the trivial
adversary probably 37% it manages to
isolate a row and then learn all the
bits you can amplify this to high
probability and you can even make it so
that all the queries the UASs they're
all the queries that you get are high
counts not 0 on counts so like low count
suppression is not going to help you
stop this sort of attack
I'm gonna skip this example it doesn't
even compose twice I'll leave it up well
Ashwin asked the question
so this is so this is you right this is
the differencing attack essentially this
is a differencing attack that works
without knowing anything about the data
and without having any prior information
but also lets you discover these
predicates without having any prior
information and also lets you discover a
very low weight predicate that that you
can that has a difference like this a
low a predicate of negligible but at
there at the end of the day there's just
a different sort of an oblivious of
differencing attack happening here if
you want to think about it I'm gonna
skip this example time so just predicate
singling out security imply differential
privacy this one I'm gonna make some of
the answer you know the answer somebody
knows the answer no somebody said no why
not it's determined it's it's not
deterministic but the example mechanism
we just saw was deterministic for
example an exact count is not
differentially private but gives you
this piece of security turns out though
that differential privacy does imply a
piece of security for any Epsilon
bounded by a constant and any way
between 0 1 over N then epsilon Delta DP
mechanism gives you outs epsilon Delta
prime piece of security
well Delta is negligible the same an
epsilon is this thing epsilon plus NW
which is bounded by epsilon plus 1 right
but probably this NW is gonna be much
smaller than 1 so some prime is like
epsilon epsilon plus 1 and the way this
saying is proved okay I really don't
have time the way this thing is proved
is basically by observing that singling
out is the type of overfitting in in a
way that you have to output it
predicates whose weight is w on the
distribution but whose weight is one in
n like matches one row in the data set W
is much smaller than 1 in n then the fit
is like way better way better by a
factor of 1 over N which is not way
better
but anyway differential privacy prevents
this sort of thing and because I don't
have time I'm not gonna I want to talk
about Canada MIDI so anonymity is
something that has been brought up a lot
but I don't think has ever been defined
or given an example so here's a data set
on the left a three anonymous the
version of this data set on the right so
what's three anonymous mean it means
that on the right every row correspond
the Left corresponds to three possible
rows on the right so you can't
distinguish this row from this row just
by looking on the right so this PSO
secured the answer is no this particular
K Gnana misers not PSO secured and why
because you can look at this and you can
say there's a 27 in the data set or 343
in the data set you can you can name
rows which is which allows you to output
predicate sub wait 2 to the minus and if
your distribution is uniform for example
which matches one room right this is a
particular example and when I presented
this at T PDP somebody was live-tweeting
it and he said that Kanan MIDI doesn't
prevent PSO security doesn't guarantee
PSS security if you don't pay attention
to the borders of the buckets but I
think Ted got the wrong lesson out of
this so more generally if we if we think
about Canada MIDI is outputting
predicates whatever these predicates are
these predicates match K rows and we
think about these the weights of these
predicates as being extremely tiny right
because K anonymity you wanted
suppresses
little as you can you want the rose to
be as specific as possible so these
predicates fee are very specific have
very low weight in the distribution so
there's an almost trivial attack in the
same way that the trivial adversary is
able to get one row out of n we can use
the same idea to get one row out of K
right so output like use the same sort
of trivial attack on a chunk of Cairo
and and fee so you output the predicate
that says it's in this bucket and it's 1
in candies so this predicate P has very
low weight it has weight less than fee
which we think is very low and also it
isolates within this chunk it's sort of
just like the trivial adversary and
actually proving that this happens you
have to use the conditional mean entropy
so thank you Adam for writing that fuzzy
extraction paper it helped us so it's a
little subtle but it works essentially
just as well as the true really yeah so
I'm gonna go a little I'm finishing so
again this is what we saw before it and
what we want to do is we want to go from
the technical results of the little
conclusions right we haven't tied the
knot we set out to do so we think that
piece of security is a is a stronger
condition than preventing gdpr singling
out so what were our results the Kanan
enmity doesn't provide PSO security so
the legal conclusion that we draw is
that kme doesn't generically prevent
gdpr singling out this is in direct
contradiction to the article 29 working
party opinion
also PSL security doesn't compose so we
think that on the on the legal side that
gdpr is singling out probably also
doesn't compose and we think that this
carries over because the counting the
counting mechanism we think the exact
count mechanism probably doesn't live in
this a yellow space so we think that
that non composition also carries over
to generally the concept of GDP are
singling out and finally we know that DP
is PS is secure and it might be some
evidence that it prevents GDP are
singling out ultimately we want to
understand where this where GDP
anonymization fits into this picture but
we don't can be sort of anyway anyway
thank you that's the end sorry for going
I'm confused by your picture because and
some of these are like some of these
categories seem to be like about you
know definitions or something like that
it's like a property of a definition not
of a yeah so I agree yeah I was thinking
this to capture I this was gonna be it
had a longer title which was like
security notions that compose or
something I satisfies the security
property the self composes they think
would be of the same type as this or
this
yes I think that's a good question
I think it's I think that the answer is
probably that trying to formalize these
concepts we used the tools that are I
know they aren't available to us as the
is the first step in that process so I
don't know if you have a different
answer to that
conclusions when developing a
theoretical concept it's convenient to
talk about supporting nominal functions
as negligible we could define 10 to the
minus 10 that's small enough for you and
and roughly the same theory will will
follow or you could even put tiny
numbers the only place where this where
the asymptotic really came in was this
we were restricting our attention when
we were stricted our attention to
weights that were negligible or to the
regime where the baseline was negligible
but the definition is at least
well-defined
for the whole regime of baselines where
even when there's not negligible and you
can talk about the concrete the concrete
advantage you can get for predicates of
say weight 10% so I think there's
nothing stopping one from doing a more
concrete analysis of the same
question
[Applause]
our next speaker is Christine tasks or
my problem I have CPAs what